[Musique]
je me souviens des histoires qui courait
propos des censeurs elle devrait ce
qu'on raconte les ailes sont les
premiers magicien de ce continent
lorsque les humains et les monstres sont
arrivés les elfes ont appris aux humains
a transformé le chaos en magie et
ensuite les humains les ont massacrés
de chaos est la chose la plus dangereuse
en ce monde
sans contrôle
au cas où vous tuera
pour toi voilà à quoi la vie se résume
des monstres hideux l'argent n'a rien
d'autre à ma portée quelque chose tu
attends
temps forts
extraordinaire
yen fort imagine la plus puissante et
femmes en ce moment donné
et tu à la hauteur
k
c'est pour excuse
tu ne peux pas fuir la destinée sous
prétexte qu'elle te terrifie
s'accomplira
trop de rillieux
je n'y arriverai pas sans toi
il importe que tu choisis
tu en sortiras maculé de sang
[Musique]